Throughout this lesson,
we covered both paid and free customer
acquisition channels in order to help
you determine what's right for your
company at your stage in development.
>> Remember to take a moment
to think about where your
touch points are with your customers.
Where do they hang out in real life and
in their online life?
You want to make sure
to meet them there.
>> And don't forget, you don't
have to chose just one channel.
You can combine multiple channels and
keep learning on the go.
As long as you make sure to
track your performance and
keep doing only the things that
show positive impact on your goals.
Which is exactly what we're
going to be covering next lesson.
Tracking and measurement.
So, we'll see you there.